hi everyone
welcome back to another vojs stream i
hope you're doing well i took a couple
weeks off
and i'm excited to be able to do this
stream on
vue.js testing this is the app i'm going
to be working on
so it's called regex breakfast i worked
on it on
my channel which if you don't know it's
faraday academy it's linked in the
description below
and i basically do lots of
django and view content between twitch
and youtube
so this is a app that i'm in the process
of redesigning but i figured it would be
good to add
some tests to it and go ahead and
install just today
so if you're here feel free to say hi in
the chat
and keep a conversation going if you
have
any questions or you want to give input
which is the whole point of a live
stream so feel free to do that
i do have some bad allergies today so if
i take myself
off camera for a second that's why
um yeah so let me go to the project
board on this
github repo
and let's go to the testing board
okay and so these are the steps and the
different areas of the application that
i'm going to test
starting with setting up the view cli
plugin for jest and which will install
again installs um view test utils and
some other things
so let's take a look at the app and give
me one second here
okay i'm back um yes so this is the app
i'm working on
so before you say anything um we were
trying out some different designs
uh trying to get this to be a retro
kind of diner theme
um yeah and so it was a couple
developers
on my stream we were trying to design it
obviously it didn't turn out that good
so i hired one designer and now
i'm working with another designer trying
to get this to
where it looks good the point of the app
is basically
to help people learn regex through going
through these different challenges
kind of like the game css sushi
if you've played that it's similar
except you're learning regex here
so basically i get a hint down here or
challenge instructions i guess and i'm
supposed to
match the characters here and then i hit
enter
and then it gets more complicated and
you start
yeah using flags and different patterns
and stuff like that
so i'm going to be writing tests for
this app today
and the first thing is setting up the
just plug-in so let me go to my terminal
i'll stop my server
my view server since this is already
this application's already set up so it
already has
a lot of i guess components it also has
a router
not really going to be testing that
today i might get into store testing
with the view x store and then the rest
are just regular
views and components vue.js components
okay but i don't have any testing at all
right now
so what i'm going to do is
i'm just going to add it from the
terminal so i'm going to do view
add and then
just let me make sure that's right so
let me go to the docs
for
okay this is this is the cookbook for
unit testing in view and i don't think
they actually have
how to install it just the just docs
just have how to install just
plainly so before i do this let me
actually just open the view ui
and that way i can search for the right
plugin for jest
okay it opened in the wrong place let me
copy this
okay so here's the view ui
it's basically a ui interface um
that i can use instead of the cli
and let's see
let me zoom out so i can see the sidebar
okay so um nw view
okay that's the different app i was
doing before so let me jump
to the correct application
import um let's see
it's in projects and
i need to find regex breakfast
are you see regex breakfast here it is
frederick's breakfast
and rojak's breakfast front there is no
back end it's just front
i just called it front so okay i'm going
to import this folder
and now i can install plug-ins inside of
this folder and it shows me what plugins
i already have
i designed it with viewify and i used
all these other plugins so
i'm going to search for actually i have
to click on add plugin
and now i can search for
just
so it's giving me view cli plugin just
puppeteer
cli plugin unit jest and it says
official here so i'm going to grab this
one
and let's see if i hover over this
the plug-in has a generator okay so i'm
going to click on this
and install ucli plug-in unit jest
okay so that's uh taking a while
to install oh sassy sorry
i think i forgot to say hi um yeah i'm
doing well
i've been meaning to put testing in some
of these apps for a while so i figured
now is a good time to do it
okay not sure how long this is going to
take
um anyone else in the chat i know
only subscribers can chat but
if anyone else is there and is a
subscriber or can subscriber to help
or can subscribe to help support free
code camp
it would be awesome to get to talk to
you
okay it's going to take
another minute i guess um
after this it should create some setup
files
for me there's no configuration that i
need to do for it so i'll do finish
installation
all right
so it's invoking invoking here this
means it's
invoking the generator which might be
creating files or updating commands or
something
it might have added a testing command to
my package.json
here yeah it did so it added this
command
which is test unit that i'm going to be
using to run the tests because this will
run the
just plug-in oh it added this testing
folder too
and one example test okay but this test
won't work because there is no more
hello world component
it's just adding a default test
all right um
let's see
continue okay so now that's installed
now sometimes here
let me zoom back out sometimes you can
go to configuration
and okay i guess just doesn't have
configuration options here
that's fine i'm going to get out of the
view ui
and now i can run my app again now that
that's set up
so npm runs serve
to run the vgs app and oh no wait
i don't want to run the app i think
because
i want to go ahead and run the tests
oh it also created this um just config
file for me
with the preset okay
um yeah so it's all set up so i should
be able to just do
and actually one more thing i'm going to
run this
testing command or
no i'm going to change the testing
command so instead of test unit i don't
have end to end test or anything else
so i'm just going to change this to test
so i can use the shorthand
all right and i'm going to get out of
this build
it doesn't want to exit the build so it
might take a second
control c is not working
okay it's almost done with the build
anyway so i'll just wait a second
there we go all right and i'm actually
going to move my terminal so i'm not
switching back and forth
across the browser for it so i'm going
to do
okay regex breakfast front now i can do
npm
test or there's also the shorthand npm t
that i can use and that runs my test
command
and it's running that one example test
that i have
okay and it's failing obviously because
it is
trying to import this component which
doesn't exist
so what i'm going to do in here i have
test slash unit
i'm going to start adding folders that
kind of match
my components actually i don't have a
very complicated folder structure here
because
it's only five so i'm just gonna add a
views folder and a components folder
and test those so let me add those
folders
i'm gonna add what about the hour
tracking app
i'm going to be working on that more on
my channel
so i want to get this app done
and the curriculum app and i'm going to
finish up the hour app
after that um yeah
uh it's i want to work on it more on
this channel but
a lot of people if i'm working on the
same project too many streams a lot of
people drop off
and there's not as much viewership
so i'm gonna i think i'm gonna finish
working on that on my twitch channel
yeah plus i'm going to be taking a break
from these dreams after today
so i just wanted to get in one kind of
different stream on here
and then take a break
mostly because i have a lot of other
stuff i have to work on
okay so i added a views folder and a
components
folder okay
um see
okay yeah let me start with components
because those are easier
so i have body draw and top bar
and let me go back to my list of things
so i set up the
just plugin that's done and
i need to implement snapshot testing
so let me do that real quick just these
three components
and if you don't know what snapshot
testing is it basically
is a rendered version of your component
that you can see in a second because it
shouldn't take me that long to set it up
and then over time you compare different
versions of your component
and you make you basically make sure you
haven't created unintended side effects
that affect your rendered html
so it can be useful in that way uh so
let me do
body and then i need to put a dot spec
suggest we'll find this i think you can
use like dot test or dot spec
but just automatically picks up files
and runs tests against them if they're
if they're called dot spec if they have
a dot spec in them
um okay draw and top bar
uh draw.spec.js
and
top bar
yeah top bar dot spec
dot js okay i have those three
components
and then i have views i'll leave those
alone for right now
so let me start with this
body and basically
what i want to do is mount
this component and then create a
snapshot from it
which is like a stringify html
of the component so uh
let me go to
um so just actually has um
the just testing suite has a lot of
things like an expect library
and it does snapshots
it takes care of snapshots for you it
has like a two html
method or something but i think it's um
or view test utils oh wait here it is
view test details adds a lot of methods
so it's better
to instead of using
the html functions of jest you can mount
it
with view test utils and then create a
snapshot
and the view test details basically
gives you a lot of
methods for handling view components
so installation so it's already
it should be installed with the just
plug-in
[Music]
so let's see
mount let me go to mount
so i need to import mount from view test
utils
and okay and then it imports the
specific component that i want to mount
so in this case i want to mount body so
be import
and import body from
i think i can do at which represents
source
i think i can use that in my test and
then slash components
slash body
then okay dot view and
let's see if that works let me write a
quick
test so this is from just
the syntax so describe um
which is going to wrap all of my tests
for this component
so i'm just going to put describe
body.view for right now
and then i need to pass a function so
let me pass
just an arrow function there and
now i can write tests inside instead of
it i really don't like
the it syntax that much um
i'm going to use the test function which
is the exact same
i think one is alias to the other but i
can't remember which one
okay so i test and then i write a short
description about what what the test is
about
um and then i can mount the component
and i'm actually going to do a snapshot
instead of
some other kind of test here so
um yeah so this is the same syntax i
need to pass a string
and i'm going to test
a snapshot
yeah i'll just put snapshot and then
another function and now inside of this
test
i'm going to mount the component which
mount the body component
and now i can do
wrapper
oh wait i need to do expect i'm going to
look up the syntax in a second
but something like expect wrapper to
match snapshot and then the first time i
run this it creates a snapshot for me
and then future times it compares
any updates to the old snapshot
okay so let me search for that so
snap shot
um to match oh i think i need to look in
the
gest docs for that snow
so here it is because it's a method on
me on the just expect library
so basically here expect
whatever component to match snapshot
which is the same thing i have here
because i've mounted my body component
and now i can expect it to match the
snapshot
so let me try running this now it might
complain that i have
these three these two files empty
but let me see
let me run my test again
and see if it works
four failed okay draw body top bar
example.spec.js oh i need to delete that
file
let me delete that example file i don't
need that
okay so um
and let me actually if this one's
failing let me see why that one's
failing
um you're trying to use
sass oh node sas is missing
um okay i don't know if i've run into
that before
but um
i have i have sas installed in my
project
but it's a peer dependency
through
i have sas and sas loader yeah
but basically view set up sas for me so
i can use it inside my
components or import it into my
main view file
um okay let me just try installing it
like it recommends
is the dev dependency
and see if that works
can you see the bottom yeah sometimes
these stream tools cut off the bottom of
my screen
all right
okay maybe no task is gonna take a
minute
and then i don't know if there's any
config
i guess i'll see if there's any config
that i need to do with sas
and the project
but i don't think there should be let me
do npm test again
all right
cannot read property getters okay good
good good good
so now i'm getting actual errors with
the component
which is good um
so and let me just run that one test
file so i think i can do
npm
let me look back up through
my commands yeah so then i just passed
the
component name to it so i can do npm
t and then pass the component name
so i'll do um
body body is my first one so i'll do
mpmt body
and then i think it will just run that
one test now
yeah good so i just wanted to run that
one
and cannot read property getters of
undefined so let me see if i have to
um do something with that so let me open
that
file
body dot view okay i'm using
a couple um utility methods
getters oh i think um let me
let me search for this getters yeah
so i think i'll have to mock getters
here
um let's see i have to create a local
view store
ux store and let me look up
the syntax for that so
i think actually it's um
wait part of you test utils so let me
look up local
not local view
okay this is a section on
testing view x
new view x dot store
all right i i import a create local view
and then i create um
a new view x store basically
all right so let me try this
let me and then i'm gonna have to
import these at the top
and see um
and actually these are absolute imports
so
i should put them here
their library imports okay
oh cool that's awesome when i save
because i set up eslint auto fixing
so it actually fixed all my imports too
i didn't see that before
all right so now i need to create a
local view instance
and i could actually create
a regular view instance by importing
just
few but this way i'm not polluting any
global state or anything um
so let me see i have
store i don't think i need i don't think
i have any separate store config here
i might import my state clone
deep
um yeah so let me do
i need to create a new local view and
then do local view dot use view x
and i'm going to do that here
um i might create a before each for this
later and now i need to create a new
store
so let me create a new store
and
all right so
i think i'll just pass an empty object
for right now oops
and let's see expect
um store okay and then i can make
expectations on the store
but i think i need to
when i mount this component i think i
can
um let's see pass in an
options object and pass the store into
the component so that way i have access
to
getters so um
yeah let me see if i can or i might have
to mock the getters
but let's see so i've created
my store
and oh yeah i need to look at the
options that i can pass
in so let me go to mount
the mount function
and see
okay so i can pass in props data
does it have the whole api for this
component options
okay the first argument is the component
the second is
uh any number of options so i have mock
stubs
i can pass in local view which is what i
want to do
um yeah because that will have
where is it yeah local view here so that
will have the store
because i'm doing view oops view.use
view x
actually wait i need to
i think i need to put passing the store
too let me see
uh config.box store
i wonder if this is this is better to
just mock the store
like stubs because then i can mock the
getters the store.getters
so actually i think this is what i want
to do and then i'm going to save this
local view because i'm going to need
that in other tests as well
so let me actually
i think here i can define mocks
but um oh yeah and for the local view
i'm going to need that for my beautify
setup as well
because i think i'm going to get some
errors about this after i fix this error
but yeah so
let's see let me set this up real quick
um
all right so config.store
um i think actually what i'm going to do
here
is oops i can do
or let me do i don't know let me just
call this
store mock this is just an object
oh wait this is not proper javascript
all right and then on here i can also do
a getters object
and then put getters on there
and then
um config.mox
um
oh yeah this will be mocking it for all
the components not just
the but i just want to do it for
the mount so let me look for mount again
go back to mount
let's see
and where is it
um here are mocks
so yeah so i can create a mock and just
pass it in
to a mox object so i'm gonna do that
here so
i'm gonna create an object here
and then i'm going to pass in i guess
the
syntax it wants me to use is dollar sign
so let me go ahead and do that and i'm
just going to take this and put it
inside of the test as well so
in here
okay
and now i can pass in this store moc so
let me take that
and
store is not defined
store here oh that's right
so let me do let's store
okay fine um
and now getters so
in my body i have this current challenge
getter
um which gets back an object of the
current challenge
and then i pull the name off of that so
what i'm going to do is just mock that
so the current challenge which
will be a function that returns
in object
oh wait to return an object i have to
wrap it
so okay
all right that should work but i'm gonna
be getting some more errors before this
actually works
so let me try this out
okay npm test that body component
and yeah so now it's complaining about
the snack bar which is because i'm using
the beautify
component library and it doesn't
recognize that
so
oh the snapshot actually passed so let
me look at the snapshot
it makes this so inside every folder
where i create snapshots it creates this
dunder snapshots folder
and then it basically
rendered yeah the
output html but it's using
these beautify components because it
doesn't know what they're supposed to be
because just can't see beautify
so i need to set up beautify to work
with just
and let me i'm just going to set this up
in this file for right now on a local
view instance
and i think it's in the
what is it the beautify
beautify library and then they have like
a
just unit testing section
oh wait no no oops
here it is come on
all right it's taking a minute to load
there we go
um go to new docs okay i just need to
set up just
so bootstrappingvedify
that's fine
test runner setup okay i'll just click
on just
all right and now
okay um oh wait
this is the actual view cli plugin just
get rid of that
um so it's just linking me away but i
need to know with beautify specifically
okay here it is so
it's saying to create a local view
which is what i already did and now
okay running before each to create new
beautify
um and before each basically runs before
every test in the file
so let me do this and last time i set
this up i did it as a global
um beautify setup because i needed it in
so many different tests
but i think it's just easier here just
to
uh oops set it up
in here um
just in the testing file
of course i have to do it in each
testing file but let me do it this way
first
okay and then when i map components i
need to pass in
local view and beautify
so i need to pass it in here
so let me do that
above so i'm passing in local view and
beautify
and uh one second let me go into my vs
code setup
because for some reason it's
yeah it's doing four spaces instead of
two
usually it auto finds it but
in debt spaces so let me do two okay
um let's see do your unit test all your
projects i would like to say that i do
but i don't
especially if they're personal projects
hi tom
um companies i've worked for often
off and on some of them have full
testing suites
unit testing uh integration testing
you know end-to-end testing and then
some of them just
say they want testing and then never get
around to testing because
they say features are more important um
yeah so i don't test i would like to
test all my projects and so i want to
get faster at testing because it feels
like every
every time i start testing an app which
is almost always for
a client i have to
re-look up all this stuff because it's
off and on when i test
so i want to start testing all my
personal projects so that i just get
better at testing in general
um yeah so
let's see i was into tdd a couple years
ago
i was trying to tdd everything like i
don't know
2016 or something and then
i think i got out of it because the
other developers around me
weren't or it's very hard to convince
people
to write so many tests i think i went
overboard with it so there's a balance
between
you know testing and yeah going too far
okay beautify uh beautify
okay i did the beautify that's good um
now it's
coming into i'm well i'm passing it in
as options in the wrapper
so let me run that test again
one failed all right um
so let me wow that's a lot of failure
um unknown custom element
v row
uh so these are all the beautify
components so it should be
it should know about these i mean i
could technically stub them
um so uh
was it jess or um
you test utils lets you stub
things so then i could say
what is it v row like v row
and just say
div or something um
but that wouldn't render any nested
components i'm
avoiding that um and then i could also
do
a shallow mount where is it instead of a
full mount
because if shallow mount automatically
stubs child components and a full mount
um doesn't basically but
i want to do a full mount so i get more
of an idea of everything that's going to
be rendered on the page
so i have to figure out why it's not
recognizing these
beautify components uh
so let me see
expect rapper
um okay
great local view i got those
am i importing wait i might need to
import
so here i'm importing
oh that was really dumb i'm not uh
importing
uh beautify and view so let me import
those
there um i think i need
view even though i'm not
necessarily using it i think i need it
in the scope
um maybe let's see
okay running a test one more time
all right let's see if it's the same
error
okay well the snapshot passed but that's
because the snapshot's not changing
because i'm getting these errors did i
register the component correctly it's
saying that i
didn't
is before each running
so let me see
and here it's doing wrapper.html um
which is that jest
which is the jest function the html but
since
i am mounting this with view test utils
i shouldn't need to do that
um so let's see beautify
creating a new beautify
i wonder if i need
shouldn't need any options
i am mounting
let's see mounting
creating a local view
um local view dot use
let me just comment these out because
it's because i'm not using them right
now
so let me run this one more time
i don't know if that's going to do
anything but i'm just getting rid of
anything extra here
let's see state getters
wrapper
yeah unknown custom element all of these
vcard recall the text field all of the
vidify components are still
unknown um
so let me take a look at this let me go
to
beautify um
props describe mount function
okay mocking viewify
blang okay i shouldn't need to mock
keep in mind you only need to stub the
surfaces that are being used such as
laying our application
you can also import these services
manually
um i'm just
i'm going to look at one of my other
projects because i think i'm a little
stuck here
unless anyone in the chat has an idea of
what i should be doing
i just can't remember the exact setup
steps that i did for vidify
so let me go to this app
and okay
so the curriculum let's see tests
so unit tests and
i do have this setup so this in this
project i have a setup file
for vuedify and
um yeah i basically
set up vuedify and then
[Music]
have this imported into my just config
so my just config is has a lot more
stuff in it here
um so
let me just copy this because actually a
lot of this was set up
because i installed just
yeah no ideas because i installed just
with the regular setup of the app
because in the vcli
you know when it asks you if you want to
set up testing right away
so it set up some of these things and
then i added a couple
and i added this setup files and
basically this setup files
this file runs before every test
so i can get
viewify wait let me just copy this whole
thing okay
copy that now i'm going to put it into
my just config
and
wait undo because i want to save the
plugin there or preset
um
okay that's fine
uh module extension
okay so now i have this test unit setup
test file
so i'm going to go ahead and copy that
file as well
and that file is basically doing almost
the same thing i'm already doing
in that one component except
it runs before every single test so
i don't think i need the export here but
i'm just going to copy the whole thing
and let me go into my tests
new file setup
tests dot js
okay so i set that up import view
view itify v dot use vitify
um okay i am
doing view dot use here i think that
made it
globally available and then i created a
local view
yeah that's weird what was i doing so i
do view.use vidify
but then i create a new view and use it
with
a local view instance i'll have to look
at what i was doing there
because it seems like i'm using a global
view dot use and then i'm using a local
view dot use beautify
and
okay but there were a lot of errors i
was getting
with the jest setup so maybe i did it to
alleviate one of those errors
okay and then let me just go to one of
my tests let me
look at i don't know
what's the easy test home test
let me look at this is just in like a
standard html section okay so it's just
mounting
and that's it i am using a full mount
here
and um let me make sure that the
snapshots aren't rendering
with the v dash yeah it's not it's
rendering as
actual divs actually how it would render
out in the dom
which is what i want okay so now i have
this setup file
um
i wonder if i have the serializer
installed
um i think i must i think that comes
with
um just when i add it as a plug-in
okay anyway i don't need local viewer
view to fi now
so let me take this out
um i will i might still need it for
a store maybe so
i'm testing the snapshot i am
mocking the store because i still need
to do that since this is
a full mount let me delete these two
imports at the top
don't need those okay let me try this
and see where it's at
npm test body
uh okay
setup files option was not found
um root directory
projects regix breakfast
okay tess
unit setup
oh setup tests dot js did i spell it
right
oh it's outside of the unit folder so
let me put it inside of the unit folder
because if i do other tests in here i'd
have an end to end folder and other
folders
and the just setup would only be for
unit testing
so let me try one more time
okay now it must have found the file
because it's running the test
oh and it failed oh this is a good
failure though
because now cool um
now see how it has v row here well now
it's rendering it as a div with class of
row
which is actually how it renders out in
the dom so
that is very very good okay
so it's failing because it doesn't match
my current snapshot
so i have to tell it to update the
snapshot because the new one is what i
want to save as the snapshot
so let me tell it to update here so
i'll do npm or npm
t and then i need to pass it
past the command to dash u dash u is for
update snapshot
um oh i forgot i forgot to run
just that one file okay but now i can
copy paste these into the other files
two failed one pass so my body one
passed and the snapshot
is updated um
okay let me get rid of that
oh let me take a look at the snapshot
yeah now it's rendering all the divs
everything is rendering out correctly
um what is this v snack oh that's a
transition
i can stub transitions which
uh i'm not going to worry about it i
think it automatically stubbed
the transition for me so if i want it to
be different like not be automatically
stubbed i might want to
put something else in there but that's
okay
i'm happy about that let me go to draw
and
okay the draw menu is
so app bar
toolbar so this is the top um
nav bar the
menu v now why is this
let me look at this
navigation i think draw i'm not even
using right now
this is very strange because all draw is
is an app bar
which is a top nav bar and
okay so let me just delete draw i'm not
going to worry about that for right now
um
so let me go to top bar and test the top
navigation bar
that would be more useful so let me get
rid of draw i think i just didn't
separate the components yet
that's what i didn't do i created the
draw component was going to put the draw
in there and then i didn't
so i'm going to test this
top bar and
where is it
topbar.spec.js so let me
i'm just going to grab this whole thing
because first i'm going to be testing
the snapshot
and i actually don't know if i need
the state yet um
oh i will need to mock the store because
i do need
the state some state off of the store um
let's see
challenge and challenges
yeah i definitely need some state here
so let me
actually undo that
oops
[Music]
and
redo i'm going to get rid of these for
right now
okay and i need to import the top bar
component so let me import top bar
and yeah it's much cleaner without
setting up view to find every single
file that was a better decision
okay so now top bar so i'm going to
describe top bar dot view here
i'm still doing the snapshot first i'm
going to mock the store
here i don't need any getters
but in state i do need to i don't know
why i have the id here actually
i think that was just the default thing
that i had
so in state i need to mock
um oh wait i do need the percent done
okay never mind so i will need to create
getters
percent done um
[Music]
yeah i'm gonna have to mock that getter
correctly later
um but for right now i'll return like a
zero or something
okay so uh let me
do getters which is an object
and i'll do percent done
and then
return zero
for right now and then in state what do
i want to mock in state so
i need to mock the challenges which is
an array and
current index which is a number
um
yeah challenges let me do challenges and
current index
so challenges
in array and then and actually i'm going
to be importing the challenges at some
point
so because i have a challenges
dot js file here with a list of all the
challenges so i can just import those in
my tests
and test off the actual challenges so
let me do what was the other thing
it was current index so
current index i'll put this at zero as
well
okay so i've mocked the store
so let me create a snapshot for the top
bar
let's see time times it's just after 11
it's been about an hour um
do mpm test run both my tests
all right maybe testing is a is a dry
topic there's not much chat about it
cannot read property small and down
oh right um i might need to mock that
because let me see small
and i thought i was using it here
let me see if i'm using it small and
no then why is it doing that that's a so
that's um
a break point um
property that i get from beautify
for small and down but why is it saying
it can't mock it here
that's weird i'm not using it
i'm not specifically referencing small
and down
so why is it saying that i might look
this up
oh maybe beautify is undefined here
so there are some weird things in
testing vidify like i had some issues
with the modal testing the modal because
it renders an
extra specific component
inside the modal
so yeah let me see
so this component i'm not doing anything
different importing
that
um
oh wait let me do medium no okay so yeah
let me
search for this and see if anyone else
has this
problem with beautify
okay
yep it seems like someone else had this
same problem from this year
i'm trying to solve this issue but i
can't oh this is
very poorly formatted okay
everyone render type error cannot read
property small
and down of undefined
um surely you will be loading beautify
as a plugin that's where the error comes
from to solve this
issue delete it from plugins and load it
as
follows
um nope that doesn't really
i don't know why this person is giving
this advice
i don't think that's very good advice
testing done by the clients in real time
yeah as everything crashes and burns
unfortunately that's how it's done a lot
of the time
actually with this um
[Music]
i don't want to say too much but this
django app i'm working on
i've been dying to write tests for it
for a while
and the client is testing it and
some business people are testing it so
hopefully
i can write a test suite at some point i
would
love to i just haven't gotten around to
it yet
um beautified js
at least like the finicky parts of the
app like that's
you know a minimum for testing
let's see
um i want to look at their github
actually
how to specifically
djs worn yeah i don't know
okay this is the same thing after
install view to find my webpack i have
this message in the console
yeah let me just look at their github
and see
if they have
okay they have foreclosed issues on this
same topic it seems
causes type error
using webpack error with apple
actually i am using app bar so this is
probably the error i'm
getting because
the error is in this app bar component
so i oh okay so i'm guessing that
beautify renders this
under the hood beautifies using small
and down
because the app bar is very specific to
the screen size
and since i am collapsing it adding a
draw
at different screen sizes so this
appears on x small
and on every other screen size it shows
all of the things in the top
oh no actually on this app this appears
on every screen size because this is
where the challenges are listed
okay but i'm guessing it is a problem
with the v app bar
so
okay so this person isn't writing
entirely in english
but he's saying he has a problem with
the app bar
[Music]
okay
they're saying if you switch to beautify
2.0 there's probably a problem with that
um yeah i've been using vidify 2.0 for a
long time so it's not an issue with that
but let me just rethink how i'm
doing this app bar i'm guessing
so let let's see if i did
oops shallow i'm gonna try
some different things so shallow mount
um which will stub all of the beautify i
think every single beautify component
actually will get stubbed
but let me try this
um oops i do undo
okay um
wait where's that oh yeah mount that was
it it's like where was i okay
shallow mount
let me
do a shallow mount so npm test
and just that component so top
i don't know why i called it top bar
seems like it should be top nav
or just nav because well the draw is
going to go in a different component but
yeah nav
might have been better um
i know actually it's only mostly one
page
so maybe top bar is okay yeah just
thinking out loud
okay so invalid prop type
check for value expected number
um oh yeah i have to mock the props on
this too
and i think i do that with
props props data
since i'm passing props into this
component
and let me see
what the props are
oh no i guess there aren't any props
okay uh so
i do need to mock so i guess it's just
data maybe it was data
i'm confused uh type check failed for
prop
value expected number oh on the progress
bar
got string so let me see what the
progress
b progress linear value okay so store
dot getters
dot percent done
expected number got string
i mean it is returning
a zero not sure why it thinks that's a
number
um okay
well i'm fighting with my own
unit test right now good jared maybe you
can help me with mine take a break from
yours
okay so
all right so i'm i'm over an hour
through the stream i'm actually gonna
push what i did so far
um just because it makes it easier if
anyone wants to take a look at it
and it only takes a second so get status
um store index
uh this match does not match let me look
at those files i didn't think i updated
them
does match
[Music]
um
okay i wonder what the diff is for that
so
let me look at the diff for these so get
diff and
i know i'm just uh not part of testing
but
i'm just curious because i didn't think
i updated these files and now it's
saying they're updated
so let
oh i know what happened uh my
automatic eslint changed some things
like it changed
lint or changed let to const because i'm
not
updating this variable anywhere okay
uh that's fine i'm guessing if i diff
the
does not match file yeah it turned lest
let to const okay that's fine i'm just
gonna
add everything then uh
code from live stream
on what's today
uh august 21st
august 21st
uh 2020 part
1.
okay i'm just going to push oh rejected
oh i know
i know why um
yeah because of these dependencies
depend about
updated some outdated dependencies
oh merge conflict and package lock.json
let me look at the merge conflict real
quick
um don't see it let me see
here we go uh
i don't know there's
a command supposed to be able to fix
this i can't remember off the top of my
head
let's see
except except both
oops
okay i think i fixed it we'll see
all right let me put fixed not fixing
fixed
merge conflicts okay
this took a lot longer than i thought
just to push the code
okay now let me do in mpmi
locally because i did update those
dependencies
uh
yeah it doesn't have to convert led to
const but i think i'm not stopping it
oh unexpected token uh what should i do
this i mean this is a live stream i'm
just gonna delete my package lock
um because i already updated it and
committed it
and i'm not too worried
but yeah don't do that at work
okay um
you missed free code camp what do you
mean i missed free code camp
are you telling i don't know i think i
missed that because it's probably been
30 seconds since you sent that message
okay now it's creating a new package
lock for me
which is unfortunate that i messed it up
but it should be okay in this project
let's see mpm
run surf yeah i think if you don't stop
the automatic uh like
what is it prettier and
um beautiful
beautifier or something and then there's
the eslint
one which is the one i use the auto
eslint i think if you don't stop it from
doing things
then it's just gonna do all of its
default
things okay npm run serve which is
change everything to const unless you're
redefining it somewhere
oh wait i don't need to surf because i'm
testing actually let me make sure the
app is still running
after that let me try to run it
all right
so how's everyone doing with the testing
is this uh too dry of a topic
for a live stream seems
maybe hard to chat about i just wrote my
own eslint rules yesterday for just
and even added in auto fixes for them oh
nice
which repo is that in
do you have it in your i know you do
your
uh whatever uh what is it
yes or no
tjw right tjw lint
on github so
everyone else who might not be in the
inside of this conversation jared
runs a vue.js group and
um yeah does a lot of
open source and has a bunch of open
source libraries
for linting and
uh yeah all all different kinds of stuff
on github
so that's why i know about them and he
has this group of libraries called like
tjw lint
um with different linting options
okay so the app is running let me go to
the browser
and see don't look at the app jared it's
very very ugly
okay yeah everything's working fine so i
didn't break anything that's good
there's a bug in here
um i was going to submit the rules to
the official
just islip plugin but it's written in
typescript so okay
so they're adding in an extra layer of
difficulty for you
um you could always raise an issue and
say hey i have all of these rules
does someone want to convert them make
it typescript friendly for me
um what was i doing oh yeah
so get rid of that i just
uh deleted my package lock reinstalled
it seems to be working okay
and now oh yeah the whole reason behind
that
was to um push my
code live so that everyone can see the
code
so if you joined i don't know if this is
in the description of the video but
that's the repo that i'm writing tests
for today
and i did just push some tests um
now wow it changed like uh
every single folder oh that's because of
the auto eslint
so i added linting accidentally with the
testing but
that's okay and now for projects
i have the testing project
implement snapshots didn't quite finish
that although i should have a checklist
for this let me turn this into an issue
so that i can add a checklist here so
body dot view component
and let me go ahead and check this off
because
it marked down because i already did it
so i do need to test the
was it top bar dot view component
and then i might test other other things
for snapshot testing
i think i'll leave snapshot testing it
here today and try to get to some other
testing in five time
but so now because i converted it to an
issue i can have
a checklist in here so i have um
yeah so i can check them off as they go
which is cool
so let's see
get rid of that okay so top bar
let me run the test again now
and see where i'm at
okay so it's still complaining about
value um
expected number string got oh it got
function
okay this was um
percent done okay so
i'm just gonna all right i'm just gonna
put a zero there
because it's returning a function to
call and
yeah anyway let me see
if that works
okay now i get a new error which is
oh yeah this is just updating the
snapshot so
let me just update the snapshot real
quick
and that should pass yeah so that passed
but
the only issue is i'm doing a shallow
mount not a full mount
and i want to be doing a full mount but
here's the top bar so basically it's
stubbing
um so because
sorry because i'm doing a shallow amount
it's stubbing all of the components
inside
um these autostub which is really ugly
and doesn't help me out a lot so
i'm going to now try to mount this
so let me see if i can mount it
actually i don't need this props data i
didn't need that because there aren't
any props i thought for a second there
were but there aren't
okay so now let me run this with a full
mount oh wait wait stop stop stop
without the dash u because that will
automatically update my snapshot that
would destroy the point of
snapshots okay failed again
what is this doing you cannot read
property with the fund to find well this
is good this is a new error
it's complaining about the v navigation
draw
cannot read property width of undefined
uh oh yeah and it's also complaining
about this
so erin getting watcher computed height
type yeah it's the same error plus the
other errors that it's getting
so i think for right now because i have
like 30 minutes left on the stream i am
going to just
leave it at shallow mount and try to fix
it later
let me put it to do in here
to do get because most of the issues are
with vidify
and i need to actually be able to sit
down and debug vidify on this
so get
this to to work
with a full mount
okay so let me run all the tests now
npm test
the full mount is working in body it's
just not working in top bar
okay and i'm gonna um
check this off here
so
yeah okay so i'm gonna check that off
and i'm gonna add
um
let's see update
just like it to do for the future so
update top
bar note update top bar
snap shot test to
use full mount
okay so i'll put that there um
now i want to do some component testing
so let's see
so test that it moves to the next
challenge when correct challenge is
input so let me run the app real quick
so npm run
serve and i'm going to open the
challenges file
and so each challenge object has all of
these attributes
it has the correct pattern
any forbidden patterns like you can't
use the period
because um it's too easy it matches any
character you're supposed to learn how
to do this
you know just as it is so i have some
forbidden patterns
i have um flags
the name of the challenge which
which you don't have to match the full
text is this part
of the text you have to match and then
info is what appears in that info box
below the challenge
so let me go here
all right um so here it's telling me to
match the whole word just by typing out
the letters for the first challenge and
then i can hit enter
so there's no like submit button here so
when i test it i'm going to have to test
that
enter that once the enter key
is pressed that it moves to the next
challenge
so um
let's see and that would be
in the body component
yeah because this is where it shows all
of the current
challenge the current challenge here
so i'm going to have to set the current
challenge
in the mock to one of these challenges
so i need to import that so let me test
let's see
and just have these three open okay so
let me import the challenges here
and right now i'll get rid of these
although i do want to fix my view x
setup in a bit
so let me but now i'm just like
doing a very basic mock here so
i'm going to import
challenges and let me do that from here
so import
challenges from
at no at
data slash challenges
and now current challenge here
is i'm just going to
let's see i'm just going to
set it equal let's say challenge zero
so um
okay uh yeah this will change the
mock-up actually or this will change the
um what do i call it the snapshot
actually so let me run this oh no i'm
still running the app
um so
oh yeah i don't think i need to be
running the app because i already know
like the flow of it how it's supposed to
move from challenge to challenge and i
need to be testing that in my tests
so i can stop the app here and
now let me do
um let me run npm test again
and see
okay didn't match the snapshot i already
know this
because it's actually
rendering you know a real challenge
so what i'm going to do is actually just
i think i'm going to update the snapshot
so let me just update that snapshot real
quick
um
dash u because i want it to
because it's never going to be an empty
object in real life
or it's never going to be an empty
object it's always going to be an actual
challenge
um so i think that's good
and i'm going to move this
out to before each actually so i'm going
to do
before each
and i'm going to define this store here
outside of it so i'll do let
dollar sign store
[Music]
yeah i just want to initialize it as an
object
and then i'm going to redefine it before
each test as this
object okay and now i need to write a
second test down here so let me do
test and this time i'm going to be
testing
that challenges
advanced
okay and
now i need to mount so i'm going to
mount this again
mount the component and i have the mock
which is the store
and let's see
i can write expect statements now so
what do i expect to happen at first
so i expect um
and let me actually look at this body
dot view component
so there's no props but i do have a lot
of
data here that i'm not um locking um
let's see
um yeah there's a lot going on in here
with the
regex testing and stuff and then
i also want to test if the snack bars
show up
so i don't need to test too much about
the dom traversal so i feel like that's
for
end to end testing where i get to render
this in an actual browser
um but who knows when i'll write run end
to end testing for this
so okay so i've mounted this and now i
want to test
that let's see
currentchallenge
currentchallenge.name
currentchallenge.info
and then in the middle i can see
that well let me go back to
i need to test that it moves to the next
challenge when correct challenge
is entered so let me step through that
and here i'm gonna do
okay so
i'm gonna have to enter uh
correct answer into
input so i'm gonna have to grab the
input and then enter the correct answer
and then i'm going to have to
um yeah i'm gonna have to
press enter to to submit the challenge
and then i'm gonna have to
check that chat
uh challenge advanced
to second challenge
okay so those are the steps i need to do
and um let's see
let me first grab the input
so that's the first thing i need to do
and i can do that let's see if
i don't uh remember the syntax for it so
let me
see if it's in here
or else i don't need wrapper functions
i actually just need um
to grab the input which i think will is
just from just
i mean yeah it's yeah uh okay so i don't
need this is just a
vjs unit testing cookbook that's not
helpful with what i'm looking for
so i'm going to um
let's see
uh dom manipulation
i just need to grab dom elements
and i can't remember exactly
expect assertions um
dom manipulation
okay so that's a jquery document.body
require
okay um it's not helpful
let me see
uh i wish i wish more people could chat
on this um
let's see
um
okay let me look for
ingest
oh yeah this is easy uh sorry i had a
brain fart there
okay so uh rapper dot find
and then i find divs i think this will
return
in array or maybe the first div
a first dom node okay that matches
um how many inputs do i have on this
page
let's see
input
um
what would it be oh it's oh that's right
i was like why isn't it called input
it's a beautify component so it's called
like v text
field okay so
v text field and
that will render since this is fully
mounted that will render as an input so
i should be able to find that
as an input and
yeah i only have one v text field so one
input
um oh no i have two
because i have
um i have this one and then i have
the other one on the page which is for
flags which should be disabled so i need
to check that also
that's disabled um
when basically what happens is it's
disabled
for all challenges unless
um yeah no flags here unless they need
flags so some of the later challenges
use the global flag like this one yeah
these use the global flags so then it's
not disabled
basically but if they don't if the
challenge doesn't need flags then that
input field is disabled
yeah i know i need to use oh thanks
jared i don't know why i didn't see chat
um
wrapper.find thanks
uh
data.testtoken datatest
yeah i need to use that definitely so
let me do wrapper.find
let's see and i need to put that on my
component
to reference it so here's the text field
that i want to reference
and i don't know
this is weird i don't know why the other
text field isn't rendering
like why is there only
one text field here
placeholder enter regex
where let me look for enter flags
what happened where's the enter flags
did i accidentally delete it wait
i need to see this now
my development server i might have
accidentally done something
so i might have to put that back either
way yeah i do want to use
the data test thanks i'm going to put
that in as soon as i figure out what i
did to my other input
all right
the chat's so quiet how are all of you
i don't know if anyone can sit through
two hours of watching someone
figure out testing
but kudos to any of you who are
wow um
yeah so let me look through my whole app
and
enter flags did this just appear this
wasn't here before and now it's here and
now i'm confused
okay um anyway so i have this one
and now i have this one and let me put
add a data test here
i'm just going to add it to the top
data test
and let's see what should i call this um
yeah i'll just call it regex okay
and now i can reference that here so i
can do
[Music]
what is it data data test
equals projects
i think so
this would be better on twitch yeah so
i'll have
a stream so i have a stream on sunday on
twitch every sunday and wednesday
i do stream on twitch and sometimes like
other random streams
but um yeah this is a good way basically
for free code camp to
earn money um and help support free code
camp
and having millions of followers
basically their chat gets out of control
if they don't have
or if they don't have some stipulations
on the chat
so yeah so i don't fault them for
making a premium chat if i had millions
of followers i don't know maybe i would
need to do that but
uh the two of you yeah jared and i have
collaborated i've had
inter i've interviewed him on my channel
as well
you can find over on my channel faraday
academy i've interviewed jared about vjs
and i don't think we talked about
testing maybe we'll do a testing one
coming up that would be fun um
okay so let me do const
input equals
this input that i just found and now
i need to do let's see
input dot value
something like input dot value and then
i can change the value
i'm not sure if this is the exact syntax
but cool um
yeah jared maybe we can do a testing
collab
if you're free at some point
um i did a views on view podcasts where
i led a discussion on unit testing
oh yeah that was a really good podcast
episode um
if you're interested views on view is a
view podcast
and jared did an episode about testing
on there
and i listened to that i think twice
so yeah it was really good so input
that that value and then i need to put
the um
value of this challenge of the solved
challenge which i am just going to take
from here so dot pattern
and i'm going to put that in here
because that's the solution
so dot pattern
and so i'll change the input value to
that and let me just see if that's the
correct syntax
uh let me search see if they have input
here
okay so you can set checked
check box input you can trigger click
i do need to trigger but i'm going to
trigger an enter
so set value here's what i want
set value of the input so
this will be oh episode 99
cool um
[Music]
input okay it's not okay so i do set
value so let me
do this i guess that's asynchronous so
i can make this function a sync
um and
[Music]
now i'm gonna do
this input
input dot set value and the value will
be
this so let me do that
and get rid of that so
enter the correct answer to the input
now i need to press enter
so they had some examples here where
it's
man i can't even remember now trigger
trigger trigger
so i need to do there's
no wait okay so i need to do input dot
uh trigger and then the event
so i need to trigger um
what is it key
i guess key press dot enter
and i think this will work
um check that the challenge advance and
here's where i actually write my expect
to test it so expect
let's see expect uh
oh what was it i just had a brain fart
okay
uh expect that the
challenge has advanced
so
what metric would i be able to test that
with
um i could spy on the function so
i probably should write a spy for the
function
and make sure that next challenge has
been called
because when i hit enter it should call
next challenge
and then
um
and then oh i couldn't check that
the store that this gets called navigate
to challenge
and i could check also that the snack
bar
shows up
maybe the snack bar stuff is better for
end-to-end testing
i think so yeah okay so next challenge
i'm going to spy on this somehow
so let's see check that
uh next challenge has been
called so i have like 10 minutes left
uh let let me see
should i do spy
um i wonder if they have any spying
docks in
you test utils
call your test runner to spy on it
set methods deprecation warning set
methods is deprecated will be removed
there's no clear path to replace that
methods
because it depends on your previous
usage
flaky tests okay so
whatever that is i'm not going to be
using it
let me look for
spy again
um detecting styles
okay um i think i'll have better luck
in here i was just seeing if there was
something in there okay keeping track of
usage spying on a mock
so i basically need to run this just.fn
yeah i know i just thought they might
have an example in the v test utils that
uses it specifically with view
but i guess i can just
do um yeah
uh let's see i need to set that as a spy
so where would i put that i guess i
would put it
in
let's see because i need to i need to
set it on the component
so i have access to
let's see if i have a wrapper here
i have access to i think the vm
so and then i have access to the methods
on the component
so now i can do um
next oh wait uh next
challenge
and here i can do
i think this is how i do it i set uh
this particular function
as a spy and then i can see if it's been
called
let's see
respect usage of the mocked class okay
is that how i use it um
i can't remember exactly let me look in
just search for it so let's see view
just spies
see if someone has a quick example
tips for unit testing the just object
installation view test details the
beginner friendly
guide to unit testing in view
let me see if this has spies in it
it's taking a while to load the page
all right
let me search the page for
spy expect spy
to have been called okay get rid of that
um
okay that's fine
so rapper dot vm dot
on robert.find just.functionmap okay
oh did you send me an example of how to
use it
so basically they're expecting the spy
to have been called
but i don't know if they give an example
of
writing the spy but basically i just
want to spy on
that function maybe i'll open discord
let me see where did you post it
okay you posted it in javascript so
if you don't know everyone this is my
discord channel uh you're welcome to
join it's a public channel and so
jared just posted an example of how to
use this
um so i'm going to copy paste this into
my code so i can zoom in on it
let me see so
body dot spec let me just put it down
here for now okay so he's doing just.spy
on rapper.vm.router dot
push okay see i can spy on the method
i'm not using the
spying on the router method but that's
just the example that he sent me
uh okay expect
rapper.vm.router.push to have been
called
with these options basically so
let me keep this down here and
so i guess i had this function
all wrong so i'm going to do
this
dot vm
i'm going to yeah
get rid of that i'm going to spy
on
[Music]
i guess it's rapper dog oh wait i have
to spy on
would this be on methods
oh wait wait
would this be on methods so if i did
methods
yeah um or no this is the
this context right
so
yeah because you're just doing dot
router
so no it's not a yeah okay
so i guess this is how it would be so
rapper spymapper.vm the next challenge
method
news.methods.thing yeah that makes sense
um so expect that
this method to have been
called and because i have five minutes
i'm going to take out the two have been
called with
and just do two have been called
and see if this passes real quick
april.vm is the same as this yeah thanks
so that's just
this context cool thanks for the help
um keypress dot
enter i also i'm pretty sure that this
will work
let me stop running that
and do mpm test
and i'm going to test just the body
component
that looks right good
oh it failed what failed syntax error
just encountered an unexpected token
you're trying to import a file which
just cannot parse
it's not plain javascript i don't think
that's the problem
um syntax error unexpected token
uh unit components body.spec.js 57.0
um okay well
that's weird oh wait i must not be
closing something there
let's see what am i not closing
um
because now it's it's complaining about
this closing
bracket so i must have deleted something
or done something wrong
but it seems like i have closing
methods for everything so
let me look at this oh okay
i'm not closing my inner test okay i
see i see so i think that that's right
clear that try running the test again
okay snapshot failed and
that's because wait
um yeah i don't know why the snapshot
failed
oh um underscores not defined
my um low dash library
must be because there's no
semicolons
i don't think so
must be because there's no semicolons i
don't understand why
the test would fail on that
right now it's complaining
that
received number of calls zero
and expected number of calls
oh he's teasing me okay
okay i get it i'm not very good with
jokes obviously
um expected number of calls
makes you a stronger developer oh
because you're using your
pinky more
let's see that's a very opinionated
statement
so it's not calling it so i think that's
a problem
not with this spy but
with um my key press dot
enter if that's actually triggering here
so
man i have like one minute uh let me
search for next challenge here and make
sure that that
is what's getting called
yeah so when i press enter it should be
calling this next
challenge method and
let's see why is it not calling the next
challenge method
um let me look up this key press
syntax because that might be what's
wrong input.trigger keypress
i don't actually know get out of that i
don't actually know if
that's the right
syntax for it testing
key mouse and other dom events
so let me look for keyboard keyboard
example
here we go um component under test this
component allows to increment decrement
the quantity using various keys
okay so it's capturing a key down event
and let me make sure that my
get commit i don't know lol okay
thanks um
let me see am i doing key press here
so yeah i'm triggering the key press
here
so that's good
now i'm testing it
and yeah they're doing wrapper.trigger
key down and then the name of the key so
it's the up arrow key
um okay mount
yeah so why isn't triggering
that function assuming that it's
getting the correct input
and it's setting that input
i mean can i log out
i think do i have to set a gest option
to be able to do console.logs from tess
um so console.log and then
input yeah let me see what that is
uh let's see
all right uh
tests okay i'm not worried about that
other one
expect just a function to have to be
called
or two have been called to match
snapshot
oh this one changed
um slightly
oh because i messed up this before so
i think i do need to let me just update
that snapshot real quick because
that was just a mistake that i made why
the snapshot is different
okay so now i can
just test the body and now it should be
just this one failing test
so there won't be a lot of other noise
selector um
okay um so maybe
expect it to have been called this is a
reference error underscore is not
defined
and that's because i think i'm importing
yeah lowdash here
is defined but never used
okay then i just don't need it oh yeah
because that's right because i moved it
into these other files here
so um
does match does not match
let's see i got rid of that
but
so i wonder because it's trying to call
this whole function here
i think maybe it's
throwing an error because the function
does a whole bunch of things
and maybe i'm just not mocking
everything
that i need to be mocking for this
function to run
okay the stream died anyway so
um this test isn't quite passing
i'm getting the correct input um
i don't think this the function is
having some errors
so i need to figure out why it's having
this particular error
and i think it's because saying
reference error underscore is not
defined
which is only when i call
some external functions like
does match and does not match so i think
that's
the issue is in those
files somehow um
yeah maybe i need to stub that function
or something
or you know make a mock of it
but yeah i am out of time now so
uh thanks for joining me i'm just gonna
take a few minutes here
and make sure everything is pushed
to github i did get some things done
like i got all the testing set up
i got a couple uh snapshots done
and then i started to test the other
components
you think the input trigger might be
wrong
um in the docs it said oh where is it
in the docs it said input dot trigger
and then i could do key press dot enter
um i don't know if i need stop
because that's what it is in the dom
here
okay let me let me run this one more
time
although the error didn't seem to have
anything to do with stop
but i can just run it and see
oops
yeah it uh failed again
all right so yeah i am going to
uh just add those files
commit um code from
live stream on august
what's today uh
august 21st on august 21st
2020 this is part two
okay and then i'll push that yeah so
like i said
i have a youtube channel that's in the
description below
and i also have a twitch channel which
is also
faraday academy if you want to check it
out and that's where i do my coding live
streams from twitch
i do other coding related videos and
sometimes
interviews here on youtube
so i'll be live on sunday if you want to
see some
view in django coding the
input trigger needs to be a native js
element like click or key up wait key
press isn't made of js
i thought key press was um
because where is it here
oh i'm taking more time uh let's see
keypress.enter.nextchallenge
i mean i could do key down i guess
so um i can't remember
why exactly i have key up and key press
to do the validate oh
because i wanted to run validation after
this i guess
oh okay that's interesting
so um
key press but it is
key press dot whatever
um i don't know because key down here so
key
key down dot down works
in triggering so i think it can be a
view
event because these work
um yeah
keydown.escape you can even pass in the
key
as in an options object
which key you want to trigger
i guess they change it and view test
details okay yeah so i really don't know
exactly what's wrong but i did just push
the code so if you're interested
in the code um i didn't quite finish
this challenge but i started working on
that test
then here's the repo i've been working
on
yeah thanks for the help jared thanks
for tuning in everyone
and yeah like jared said i have a
youtube channel check me out on twitch
and if you want to continue the
conversation you're welcome to join me
on discord otherwise i will see you
later thanks for a fun stream today